دكتور مصطفى مرحبا بك و ب قبل ان قبل ان
نبدا سؤالنا وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تقول بان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن يرجئ زيارته
المرتقبه لاسرائيل من يوم الجمعه الى
الاسبوع ال القادم سيد مصطفى البرغوثي هل
هل ترى اي علاقه بين هذا الخبر ارجاء
زياره
بلينكن المرتقبه الى اسرائيل وعمليه
اغتيال صالح العاروري في الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت بالتاكيد هناك علاقه ولكن قبل ان
اجيب يعني دعني اقول اننا نتقدم باحر
مشاعر التضامن والتعازي ليس فقط للاخوه في
حركه حماس بل لكل شعبنا الفلسطيني على
اغتيال الاغتيال الجبان المجرم لهذا
القائد
الوطني الكبير الذي كان رمز
ليس فقط للنضال والكفاح والمقاومه بل كان
ايضا رجل وحده وطنيه وعنوانا ورمزا للجهود
من اجل وحده نضال الشعب الفلسطيني ووحدته
الوطنيه بشكل عام هو اسرائيليون يظن انهم
عملوا يعني جريمه وهم فعلا عملوا جريمه
ولكن الشيخ صالح العاروري كان يتمنى
الشهاده وكما قالت شقيقته قبل قليل نال ما
كان يتمناه والاسرائيليون لا يفهموا ان
اغتيال الق هذا لا يضعف النضال الوطني
الفلسطيني ولا يضعف المقاومه الاغتيال
الشهيد ياسر عرفات والشهيد احمد ياسين
والشهيد ابو علي مصطفى لم يزد المقاومه
الا ضراوه وقوه ولم يزد الشعب الفلسطيني
الا اصرارا على نيل الحريه الولايات
المتحده طبعا متورطه في جرائم الحرب التي
ترتكب ضد الشعب الفلسطيني اذا لاحظتم من
كل التصريحات الاسرائيليه اولا امتناع
اسرائيل رسميا عن اعلان تبنيها لهذه
العمليه ومن ثم طبيعه التصريحات التي صدرت
كان انها تقول نحن لا نريد ان ندخل الان
في معركه مع لبنان المساله محصوره فقط في
في غزه وفي حركه حماس هم في الواقع يعتدوا
مش على حركه حماس على كل الشعب الفلسطيني
وعلى كل مناضلي الشعب الفلسطيني وعملهم
الذي قاموا به الان يمكن ان يجر المنطقه
الى انفجار شامل انا اعتقد ان بلينكن كان
يريد ان ياتي لاسرائيل ليقول
لهم كيف ستنه ما فشلتم في تحقيقه الان هو
يتوقع طبعا ردود فعل الكبيره على ما جرى
وربما يكون هذا سبب تاجيله للزياره اي
ولكن في نهايه المطاف بلينكن كان من اكبر
المشجعين على استمرار العدوان
وتصعيده رغم انه الان الاداره الامريكيه
تشعر بقلق شديد جدا بسبب انحدار مكانتها
في المنطقه وليس فقط في الشرق الاوسط بل
في العالم باسره وبسبب ال حتى تمرد واسع
في صفوف الشعب الامريكي على سياسه بايدن
ومعارض غالبيه الشعب الامريكي لهذه هذا
التورط ليس فقط في السكوت على العدوان بل
التورط في المشاركه فيه بشكل كامل وواضح
اها طيب اي ابقى معك دكتور
مصطفى يعني نتحدث هنا عن تاجيل زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن الى الى
اسرائيل ربما تقول يتوقع ردا ما على
اغتيال العروره لكن الى اي مدى يمكن برايك
ان ت تدرج هذه العمليه عمليه
الاغتيال يعني تدخلا امريكيا مباشرا هنا
من اجل وضع حد لكل ما يجري ومنع اتساع
الصراع اكثر مما هو حاليا في قطاع غزه وا
الجبهه الجنوبيه في
لبنان هناك جانبان للمساله اولا ماذا يريد
نتنياهو نتنياهو يريد توسيع العدوان
وتوسيع الحرب ويتمنى ان تبدا حربا شامله
مع لبنان وان امكن حربا اقليميه كامله
ويتمنى ان يورط الولايات المتحده في حرب
مباشره مع ايران هذا بدون شك اهدافنا هذه
بدون شك اهداف نتنياهو وهو كما يقول حتى
كثيرون من الصحفيون الاسرائيليون هذا
الرجل يخوض معركه من اجل شخصه لانه يعرف
ان وقف العدوان والحرب سيعني نهايته
السياسيه ويعني انه سيذهب الى السجن
بالتاكيد بالتالي هو وليس فقط هو وجانت
ايضا وقائد الجيش الاسرائيلي كله سيحاسب
على فشل اسرائيل في 7 اكتوبر ولذلك هم
معنيون بتصعيد هذا العدوان الولايات
المتحده من جانب اخر الولايات المتحده لها
وجهه نظر على ما يبدو مختلفه الولايات
المتحده سبب ترددها وسبب ضغطها ربما على
اسرائيل الان وان كان ليس ضغطا كافيا انها
تشعر ان اسرائيل فشلت فشلت في غزه فشلت في
كسر المقاومه فشل فشلت في اعاده الاحت